[Musique]
ils posent tous ensemble pour la photo
souvenir
les élus du conseil départemental
entouré des trente quatre occupants des
boucan des eaux de sans souci
ils viennent tout juste de signer avec
le département une convention qui
régularisent leur statut d' occupons sur
l'e book ont installé en plein coeur de
l'espace naturel sensible de sans souci
nous avons bien sûr en gestion ces 450
hectares qui des espaces naturels
sensibles mais ce que nous avons voulu
ne pas écarter les habitants que les
habitants soient eux mêmes acteurs de la
préservation de ces espaces est donc
pour l'heure a dit d'art quand vous
allez pouvoir continuer à garder votre
book of petite case en tôle à planter ce
que vous aviez l'habitude mais allons
ensemble travailler pour préserver la
forêt cette forêt des hauts de son souci
parce qu'il ya dans cette forêt des
espèces rares des espèces indigènes qui
convient donc de préserver un projet
ambitieux qui permettra aux visiteurs de
découvrir la biodiversité de ce site
ainsi que les activités agricoles et le
mode de vie traditionnel perpétuer au
sein d'e books en main le boucan ben moi
c'est pas d'électricité pas d'eau
courante
c
bougies le fait de boire ya pas de gaz
lui n'y a pas de
mondiale à l'ancienne quoi j'exploite ça
te jugera niyum haricots la culture
qu'on arrive à le département souhaite
valoriser l'agrotourisme sur le ns2 sans
souci il prévoit également la
restauration et la replantation de 50
hectares de forêt avec des espèces
végétales indigènes et endémiques des
hauts de saint paul
[Musique]